functions are a really important
mathematical object because if you've
got another color there you've written
this definition down they connect really
really important ideas together and
there are three which I can see in here
okay or two-and-a-half the first is this
idea of a mathematical rule okay so this
is you've actually seen these kinds of
things before we would substitute the
word relationship in here where you've
got two quantities two values and they
are tied to each other in some
particular way I'm gonna give you some
examples of this in a minute
so there's a relationship between them
just like for instance there's a
relationship between your age and your
height or your height and your weight
it's not a simple relationship it's not
like everyone who is exactly this has
exactly that but they are clearly
connected in some way right so I guess
you could say connection is another word
it's a connection or a relationship but
rule is the word that you will see most
often that's the first idea the other
idea connects these two words okay
inputs and outputs so we have a
particular word that you already know
that covers both of these their values
that can change when you've got values
that can change we call them it's that's
what the vedas anyone know we call them
variables because as the word suggests
they varied right so variables as
opposed to constants they change the
idea here is you change the input you
change the output they both vary
okay the input we call the independent
variable and the output is what sort of
depends on the input like you change
this and this will become something else
so we call the output the dependent
variable so exploring independent and
dependent variables are kind of they're
really important because we're very
interested in numbers as they change now
this is an idea that you've met before
we've just not put formal language or
notation underneath it so let me give
you some quick examples okay let's think
about something like this let's let's
I'll give you a head for okay
why equals say 2x minus 3 this is a
function okay let's see why it is it's a
it's a mathematical rule well you put
something in you'll get something out
based on each input and each output
right so I could we'll do this for the
first one we're gonna do it for any
others I could draw a really small table
of values down here like so we'll do it
just for the sake of illustration but we
won't do it with any of the others if I
put in an X that's the input that's the
independent variable let's pick some
values like say 0 1 & 2 for each of
those inputs I will get an output right
when x is 0 what's Y negative 3 when X
is 1 I'm gonna get negative 1 and it
looks like this one will be 1 okay so
you can see each input gives you one
output no drivers okay this is the
inputs of these Rapids we know lots of
other functions as well let me give you
another example y equals x squared we
won't do the table of values for this
one because you get what's going on and
I think you can think of the numbers
would be quite easily if we do the same
inputs 0 1 & 2 then what outputs will I
get for 0 1 & 2 0 squared is 0 1 squared
is 1 and 2 squared is 4 so 0 1 & 2
produce 0 1 & 4 that's all fine ok now
let me give you an example and I'll put
this in a different color if you have a
different color that'd be great let me
give you the example of something that
is the daughter function okay so this is
not a function okay noting that I always
pretty much use X's as inputs and Y's as
outputs let's think about this instead
hmm now this is still a mathematical
rule there is still a connection a
relationship between x and y here just
like there was in our previous two
examples okay but this isn't a function
for a very particular reason
give me an input given input
three-three oh dude okay so if I put in
3 for X that's my input okay I'll do it
over yeah whoops x equals 3 what happens
when we try and find out what the output
is well I'll get Y squared equals 3 do
you see that well now hold on a second
when I say what is the output there
isn't just one output is there there are
actually two there are two solutions
what are they
plus or minus root three very good we
switch done okay so even though you get
an output out of you because you
actually get several outputs and that's
not a function I only want one okay so
that's why these guys are okay but this
guys are done and there's actually quite
a few things that you already know that
I also does here's another sale orange
here's another example of a not function
what's this shame do you recognize it
yet this is a circle can you see why
it's not a function because if I put in
an X value let's try x equals zero right
then what happens when I try and find
out the output well I'll get 0 plus y
squared which is just Y squared equals 1
and again I'm like oh I have lots of
outputs I've got two that's not very
useful okay